we've already seen multiple times that
glycolysis is the process where we start
with a glucose molecule which has six
carbons and we're able to break it down
into two pyruvate molecules which each
have three carbons and in the process of
doing so we produce a net of two atps we
reduce nad plus to nadh we're adding a
hydride anion so this is reduction
this is reduction
going on right over there
and then we say well what happens and of
course we have the water some water
produced and some hydrogen ions but then
the next question is well what happens
next and we could talk about cellular
respiration and that's what will happen
in many organisms including it's
happening in my body right now in order
for me to generate as much atp as
possible that's why i inhale oxygen
because that oxygen is needed for
cellular respiration but sometimes there
isn't oxygen around or i'm the type of
organism that just doesn't use oxygen or
doesn't conduct cellular respiration now
we've already seen one example of that
and that was lactic acid fermentation
it's a way of getting of recycling these
nadhs oxidizing them back
oxidizing them back to nad plus so this
oxidation
this oxidation from nadh to nad plus
this is what we do in fermentation
actually both variations of fermentation
that we're going to talk about in lactic
acid fermentation we talked about taking
the pyruvates to oxidize the nadh and in
doing so the pyruvate turns into lactic
acid and that's used in yogurt
production and sauerkraut it's also used
in your muscles when your muscles run
out of oxygen if you're kind of
sprinting or you're lifting some really
really really heavy weights you probably
have some lactic acid fermentation going
on but now we're going to talk about
another type of fermentation and that is
alcohol fermination
alcohol
alcohol or sometimes called ethanol
ferminate fermentation
ethanol fermentation because when we
talk about drinking alcohol we're
talking about ethanol
ethanol
for mentation and as you might guess
this is the process by which alcohol is
produced and things like bread it's used
in baking a lot but let's first think
about the reaction and then we'll talk
about maybe where you might have
encountered it last so we saw that
pyruvate
when we finish glycolysis we have so we
have for each molecule of glucose we
have two molecules of pyruvate and so
each of these molecules of pyruvate the
first step is they lose their carboxyl
group right over here and that's
facilitated by pyruvate decarboxylase
you can this name is all about getting
rid of a pyruvate carboxyl group and you
can see when you remove a carboxyl group
it's a carbon and two oxygens that is
going to be and i'm not showing you the
detailed mechanism here but that's going
to be a carbon dioxide that is released
and then what's left over
what's left over and once again i'm not
showing you the detailed mechanism
but you can account at least for the
various atoms
what's left over is
acetaldehyde acetaldehyde i have trouble
i have trouble saying that and then the
next step the acetaldehyde can be
reduced one way you think about it you
can say it's reduced by the nadh to turn
into ethanol it's a similar mechanism to
what we saw in lactic acid fermentation
where we went from pyruvate to lactic
acid but now it's acetaldehyde going to
ethanol so this right over here
this is
this is reduced
reduced it gains a hydride one way to
think about it is it's gaining a hydride
anion and in the process of this is
being reduced the nadh is being oxidized
so this
this is being oxidized
and the whole point of this the reason
why it occurs on is so that you can
oxidize the nadh to have to have more
fresh nad plus for glycolysis to occur
again and as i mentioned in the video on
lactic acid fermentation it's a little
bit of a shame because the pyruvate has
still has energy into it if you had
oxygen around you could have cellular
respiration you can go into the krebs
cycle the citric acid cycle
and derive more energy from it the nadh
also the process of oxidizing it in
theory you can use it to generate more
energy but we're not doing that when we
do either type of fermentation whether
ethanol fermentation or we're talking
about lactic acid fermentation but this
is a process that has proven very useful
for human civilization
this right over here the most famous
actor when we're talking about when
we're talking about ethanol fermentation
or alcohol fermentation is this
character right over here this is a
yeast cell
yeasts are categorized as fungi
that is a e cell it's a handful of
micrometers in diameter although they
can vary and variations of yeast are
used in things
like bread making and wine making or
alcohol production beer whatever you
want to talk about
because what the yeast does it uses it
digests the sugar it performs glycolysis
and then it performs alcohol
fermentation what makes bread so fluffy
is this step right over here when the
carbon when the carboxyl group gets
stripped off of the pyruvate facilitated
by the pyruvate decarboxylase and the
carbon dioxide gets released it makes
the bread fluffy it bubbles through the
the dough and gives it this nice spongy
flavor but you also have ethanol being
produced so it's actually an interesting
fact that a lot of bread you know i've
been reading up on it it's a lot of the
ethanol might get baked off but bread
will usually have trace amounts trace
amounts of alcohol in it
so bread will have trace amounts
trace amounts of ethanol in it because
the whole process you're using yeast to
leaven the bread
to give it this fluffiness that yeast is
performing glycolysis and alcohol
fermentation it's producing ethanol in
the process the carbon dioxide that
gives the fluffiness but there's still
going to be some trace trace amounts of
trace amounts of ethanol now of course
if you're talking about wine production
your goal is to get to the actual
ethanol which we view as just
traditional drinking alcohol so yeast
plays a a fairly important role in in
our society